so habe ich mir sagen wir da am
truppenübungsplatz lizum was sie draußen
ist es über schwere maschinengewehr
wir haben wir uns zur verteidigung
eingerichtet und bekämpfen ziele die
richtung für 114 g/t auf flächen ziele
1500 meter auf punktuelle 1000 meter auf
luft zähler
natürlich mit der dementsprechenden
flieger wieder fette 1000 meter und
gleich gepanzerte fahrzeuge also
fahrzeug stoppen auf 500 meter gut
wichtige ressourcen sowie einen voll
automatischen waffen
dass der lauf wechselt werden muss eine
gewisse kerntemperatur erreicht wenn der
laut haas wird der kunst sein dass sich
die patronen selber entzünden und
ungeplante schussabgabe innerhalb von
der waffe auf folgt sagen euch das jetzt
einmal schnell vorlauf wechsel unter
minute sein
schauen wir mal dass herr cameron sätze
lang seine zeit gespielt aber denkt dass
haut hin auf wechsel
[Musik]
perfekt die war für mich geladen werden
von dresden geht druck mehr fahrbereit